I feel like we're too 90s commercial
right now for cereal today we are trying
out sour patch kids cereal I'm actually
really scared yeah sorry guys kids do
you like him I love their my favorite
candy I know you like sour patch kit
review I like sour patch kit what about
sweet and sour chicken
I love sleeves our chicken our den sweet
I'm really scared
these just look like a little colorful
turd are you okay no milk creeps me out
sometimes in the fact that it's gonna be
sour milk like that's their tagline like
first there's sour then there's sweet so
I'm like what is that gonna do to this
milk I like fruit loops I just had them
this morning yeah okay I'm too excited
about this all right bring on the sour
patch kids cereal that yeah yeah give it
to us you can smell it from the top and
it smells like a bag of Sour Patch Kids
so like I initially hated it and then I
loved it but I've like this abrahan i
like cardboard mom okay well that is
literally because this is a bag of
cardboard and and little ice sugar so
like yes
are you one of those crazy people who
put some milk embarrassed they're
smaller than it is much smaller like I
might why would you just have a bowl of
me then you have a bowl of milk I feel
like they kind of look like kids
it's like eating little people you're
poor in a lot of those poor it up Cheers
a little bit / you like a lot I don't
like I like the right amount of milk a
lot of milk and I eat cereal oh okay
mm-hmm there are layers to this I'm
confused you don't taste like a little
bit of sour how much I know I went on a
roller coaster because I didn't like it
and then I was like not bad and then it
came back to being like okay no I hate
this and then I was a wait a minute wait
a minute let the flavors say the
sourness is freaking me out
it does taste like sour patch kids and
it doesn't get sweeter it just a seller
this is not as upsetting as I thought it
would be I feel like I'm eating candy
which feels wrong for breakfast I said
I'm eating cereal if he does miss food -
yeah I get a little bit about it does
taste like it has absorb some sweetness
it's not that this tastes like a cereal
from the nineties fruit is that the one
with the bird so I have like the
aftertaste of tricks the whole entire
time but then it's sour I don't even
know what trips taste like it does taste
like a slightly sour hinted sour okay I
was just gonna say these tastes like
sour fruit loops
yo it's truly a trick Wow plot twist
sour patch kids are all a marketing ploy
for the Trix cereal and this is the
rabbits doing paint literally made the
cereal and it's autumn like gotcha it's
actually just our trees I honestly I
think so revenge on the children that
never gave them any
I hope he is he's hurting get them all
back I would probably buy this which I'm
leave it the thumbs up [ __ ] it tastes
like straight candy when you just eat it
yeah it's like a kid cereal what I eat
this yeah I'm not mad at a crow it just
tastes like okay other cereal I'm sure
children will enjoy this I probably eat
it again why do I keep eating it
[Music]
[Music]